people of the internet today we're
unboxing what I think is the best
looking Pro Controller Nintendo has made
for the switch so far it's the Legend of
Zelda tears of the Kingdom Edition you
can see the packaging includes the
circular patterns we've seen throughout
Nintendo's marketing for tears of the
Kingdom on the sides you get an up close
look at the controller from two
different angles and then on the back
there's information about setting up
your Pro Controller for your switch
opening up the box now and you'll see
the controller does come wrapped inside
a protective foam pouch it also includes
a USBC to USB a cable so you can plug
this directly into your switch dock or
charge with a USB a power adapter if you
have one note it is not included in the
package now with the controller fully
unboxed you can see the classic Zelda
gold and I have to say it looks really
good against the dark gray of the rest
of the controller upon closer inspection
though you'll start to notice the finer
details on the controller like the
Triforce here in the center even with
the designs the dark gray plastic does
still have the slight translucence like
on the original Pro Controller although
I do think the new controller is just a
little bit darker with that effect
especially on the front it could also
just be the overall patterns on the
front make it a little bit harder to
notice the translucence is there on the
back as well however the Zelda model has
the Nintendo switch logo etched in the
center rather than the standard Nintendo
logo which is what was used for the
original Pro Controller and that takes
us to the part of this controller that I
expect will be the most divisive and
it's the white handle on the right side
I think it looks pretty good here and
definitely helps the controller stand
out but seeing it next to my original
Pro I do wonder if the simpler black
would have looked even better the
buttons triggers and analog sticks are
still very solid just like the original
my face buttons on the newer controller
do feel a bit softer with slightly more
give to them but that could be because
I've had my original Pro since the
launch of the switch and have just had
more time to break it in overall I still
feel like the switch Pro Controller is
one of the best feeling controllers
Nintendo has ever made I would prefer a
slight bit more resistance on the analog
sticks but that's really just a minor
gripe on what is otherwise a fantastic
controller now if you want to get your
hands on one of these they retail for
74.99 in the US right now they're mostly
sold out but I have seen a few of them
popping in and out of stock at times
across websites like Best Buy Target and
Amazon hopefully Nintendo will continue
to keep the supply coming on these since
I do expect they will be an incredibly
popular controller but what do you guys
think is this the best Pro Controller
Nintendo has ever done let me know in
the comments below as always thank you
all so much for watching I'll talk to
you again soon